barroso un moulin rouge c'est bien les
transports en commun parisiens mais il
manque un petit peu de fréquences et
votre n en pense quoi
c'est vraiment le moment de poser ces
questions-là le chapitre iii les matchs
en plein délire là cela ne coupez pas
dans mon truc plus bas du frérot a ouais
c'était quoi la question il ya beaucoup
trop de monde il ya peu des pc des cas
cas partout c'est hélas et votre sens
bon square bon comment votre soeur le
système enfin souvent le transport mais
parfois ça fait un peu mal au cul au
corps suivie dans une grande capitale
européenne qui s'appelle rome et où il
ya des transports en commun mais c'est
une vraie catastrophe parce qu'il
fonctionne sur dix ont le temps de métro
ferment à 10 heures le soir il y a que
deux lignes
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens toujours un incident
technique
un malaise de voyages j'en ai marre et
vauxhall en pense quoi de ce qu'on veut
c'est que même quand on prend les
transports c'est resté faible seuls y'a
pas de soucis à prendre les transports
mais on reste fait je suis toujours ok
ok automne hiver